I get attached to things like really
attached hey babe do you need a new
toothbrush
oh no I've had this one since I was a
kid wait what and quickly very very
quickly hi I'm Anna nice to meet you I
read no I'm sorry this is my no I don't
do it consciously I can't help it I'm an
imaginative person so of course I
immediately fantasize about the outcome
of things the moment the possibility
presents itself whether it's a job
opportunity I'm excited about so your
resume says you're proficient with Adobe
Premiere Pro CC I'm gonna like it here
excuse me I mean you guys have kombucha
on tap that is crazy yeah I love LA oh
and the office labs are so like Fung
Shui you know what I should probably get
back to my desk I've got a lot of work
to do uh or if I meet a guy and we have
great chemistry
well I'm Japanese Hawaiian so I'm
historically self-destructive you're
funny
thank you so what are your emotional
triggers your attachment style your
level of self-awareness of your
childhood traumas and how are you
working to overcome them oh and what's
your birth time well look if we're gonna
make this work I'm gonna need to know
your ascendant we had just a TV show
I hear this show is really good but
there's only two seasons out and there's
this rumor that it gets canceled do I
bother and what if I really love it and
I know I'm setting myself up for huge
disappointments because you don't always
get that job and sometimes that guy
doesn't call you for a second date and
most definitely that show is gonna get
cancelled but on the other side of the
extremist spectrum never getting
invested in anything kind of sucks too
I mean without the hope of anything
happening life is just hopeless and that
would be definitely way less fun than
the emotional roller coaster of becoming
overly attached to something
instantaneously and riding the high of
expectations
and of course the answer always lies in
moderation like I don't know how many
times I have to learn this lesson but
here we are again a decade on YouTube
and I'm still rediscovering that all of
my problems usually have the same answer
you know sometimes it feels like when
you get older your problems just sort of
like mutate like bacteria or something
and they become smarter and stronger and
you as the anti body have to remember
hey wait a second you're the same
problem I dealt with like two years ago
only a right to version cuz this is
bullsh
so now I'm striving to pace out my
emotional investment in all
possibilities in a healthy organic way
instead of just like shoving all of my
expectations into this one desired
outcome so that anything other than what
I imagined will just leave me in despair
I self hope for what will happen but I
don't immediately get married to the
idea that this job is mine this boy is
mine or that's gonna be show better go
on for forty three seasons instead I try
to actively and consciously just trust
that if the job is mine it'll be mine if
that's the right boy for me it'll work
out I surrender everything to the
universe and I know that it's gonna
unfold exactly as it should and I
immediately freak out and think that's
all wrong and I surrender again and the
cycle repeats forever and ever and ever
and ever until we die yay I'm Anna Akana
don't get attached to an outdated outro
that no longer feels awesome thank you
to Squarespace for sponsoring today's
video Squarespace has beautiful
award-winning templates and an
all-in-one platform so there's no need
to install patches or upgrades at
they have a 24-hour customer service for
all your technical and emotional support
questions and a simple and unique domain
set of experience with Squarespace you
can create any kind of website whether
you're an overly attached girlfriend a
super virus or Sagittarius son Capricorn
rising go to squarespace.com sash
banister your free trial today and use
the offer code ana for 10% off at
checkout
[Music]